okay thank you David thank you all for
coming here so I'm going to talk about
improved approximation algorithms for
non pre-emptive scheduling problems
using time index to help you relaxations
so we are going to focus on a bunch of
problems and here is a common setup for
all those problems so we are given a set
J of jobs and the set M of machines and
each job J has a weight and our
objective is to minimize the sum of
weighted combination time overall jobs J
so that is some J / j some JM j WJ x ej
where CJ is the completion time of g so
you can think of job as one interval in
on a machine in a solution and the
competition time of that job is right
and the point of the interval so for
this schedule this red job has
combination time for and this orange job
has company time six and this black your
combination time you know and our goal
is to minimize the sum and before we
talk about the specific problems we are
trying to solve and let me introduce a
very convenient notation introduced by
Graham ETL and is called alpha beta
gamma notation for scheduling problems
so a far basically denotes the machine
model so we can have alpha equals P so
four identical machines so in this model
all the jobs all the machines are
identical so for each job J you have a
size PG and the processing time of G on
machine I is just a PJ and we also have
unrelated machine model here for every
job Gia and every machine I you have a P
idea that's the processing time of job J
or machine I so this matrix P can be
and the in-between we also have a queue
so it's called a reunited machine and in
this model every job has a size every
machine has a speed so the processing
time of job Jian machine is just a PG /
a sigh size / speed and so beta will
denote additional constraints we have
for all those problems so in this talk
we are going to focus on three
constraints why is r.j. so that says
that a job J may have a rival time RJ so
you cannot process this job before its
arrival time and you are we or we may
also have precedence constraints so we
require J to proceed G prime that means
J prime can only start after J companies
so those two constraints will make the
problem harder but the third one will
make the problem easier so it says all
jobs are identical so without loss of
generality we can assume all jobs have
size 1 and the camera we are denoted the
objective function we're trying to
optimize and in this talk we are only
going to focus on the way to the
companies in time ok so here are our
results and first consider the identical
machine model so if you don't have
precedence constraints then you can
basically get a PETA's so that's easy so
we will have precedence constraints for
identical Mishimoto so for the basic
problem we get a two plus two long two
approximation which improves the
previous four approximation due to muni
you tell and for the special case where
all jobs are identical the same paper
gave three approximation and we improved
it one plus root 2 and if machine model
is a related machine model then to dark
energy more scalable order of log n
approximation where m is the number of
machines and we improve this nightly by
a knock-knock M vector so then we
consider the real unrelated emotion
model
so in the problem of minimizing the
weight in the competition time in the
unrelated emission model breakthrough
result of pencils through endeavors and
the service I gave were 11.5 minus sign
approximation improving the previous 1.5
approximation algorithms and but that
epsilon is tiny and we also get a 1.5
minus some epsilon approximation and
this is also tiny but one technical
improvement is that our algorithm is
based on a very natural LP relaxation
for the problem and which I'm going to
define soon
so when jobs have arrival times and the
previous based approximation ratio is Q
and we improved it to one point seven
eight sorry one point eight seven eight
six and those results are based on two
papers one joint work with sungeum and
one by myself okay so a major so in this
talk I'm going to only focus on those
two results and the scheduling on
identical machines with precedence
constraints and the scheduling on
originated machines when jobs have
arrived what hands and the major theme
of all the results we have is the use of
time index to LP relaxation so those are
really natural air purity axioms for
those problems but surprisingly they are
not considerate before explicitly in the
literature I think partly because of two
reasons one is all those previous
results they don't need this stronger LP
so the results can be obtained using
some weaker LP relaxation and the second
in practice if you have those time
indexed variables the LP size is going
to be huge and but we use the time index
LP relaxation to improve all those
results so what is a general framework
for this LP relaxation well it's very
simple so remember for every job
J we need to choose a machine I and we
need to choose a starting time ace so we
will use x IJ s
to denote whether job J is scheduled on
wishing eye
we start in time s or not so it's
convenient to think of this X IJ of a
variable is associated with a rectangle
of height X IJ s from s to X plus P IJ
then you can see we require that the
total height of all rectangles on
machine I covering one time point should
be at most one so that means I can only
have one job being processed at any time
and across different machines for the
same job the total height should be
exactly 1 and also the completion time
is just we take all the right points of
the rectangles for job chair and takes
average wherever it is with respect to
the heights of rectangles and also we
can capture the precedence constraints
so there is a stronger set of
constraints for this constraint but in
this talk we we are only use these
services sufficient so we just require
the competition time of J prime to be at
least as a completion time of j + PG
prime ok so this is a constraint we are
going to use ok now we move to the two
results we have and you can see once we
have this time indexed LP relaxation and
we know the previous results and it's
not hard to derive those results using
the helpee relaxations so first I'll
talk about the elimination invasion
scheduling when jobs have arrival times
so remember in this problem we have an
winded innovation model every job G has
a PID on every machine I so we have a
arrival time RJ for each job J and so we
in the lp relaxation you can think of we
have a rectangle for each machine and
the total height of rectangles covering
each time point on every machine i is at
most one and across different machines
for the same job you have total high 12
rectangles okay so our algorithm is
actually based on the previous two
approximation algorithm and then
identify the loose part of the analysis
and improve that by our time indexed LP
relaxation so what is the to
approximation algorithm using our LP so
we first to solve the LP to get a set of
rectangles then for each job Jay we were
independently to the following so
remember for every job J we have a total
height one of rectangles and each
rectangle is indexed by Machine I and
starting time a so I'm going to randomly
choose one according to this
distribution so like I J's SJ q be the
index of the rectangle for job J and
then conditioned on this rectangle I'm
going to choose the offset tau J so
which is uniformly distributed between
the starting point and ending point of
this rectangle so this is my toe J and
after I've seen like T the IG HT and the
tau J I can just schedule the jobs from
machine by machine so for each machine I
I will schedule all jobs with IJ equals
I on this machine I so the schedule is i
was following so I just pretend this cow
J is Jesus arrival time and then I do
this greedy scheduling in this order so
when a job comes I will schedule it as
early as possible so that means this job
Jesus starts at time tau G what starts
when the previous job companies so for
example here I schedule a job here tau J
is here the next job I scheduled here
tau J is he
so as scheduled immediately after the
ready job companies and the orangie job
are scheduled here and this job I
scheduled it here so this is a greedy
schedule question okay well now a nice
gesture assumes a tea is polynomially
bounded so by losing our nog you want
has a plan factor you can reduce the
number of tea from the time points to
polynomial convenient yes not for this
particular problem this particular not
for this particular problem we need do
they have an improved on without its
constant was our weenie
I finally user the non-preemptive
operational bid
it's not pre-emptive aversion may be
okay I would check that okay so this is
a visa and so what is the - what's
analysis for the - approximation ratio
so we are going to analyze the most japa
by jobs focus on each job chair I will
analyze they expected a competition time
of job Jay and I were bounded by two
times the fraction or competition time
and so how can I do this well I first
have fixed this rectangle and the offset
for job J and I'm conditioned on those
three parameters so the competition time
CJ will be the sum of three parts so
first apart is actually the total names
of jobs G prime that are scheduled on
washing I but scheduled before or G so
that means with tau n is smaller than
tau G so second apart is the total
length of idle times before tau G so
that we are contributed to the
completion time of CJ and the final is
just P IJ the length of G on machine I
so it's not hard to bound the first term
by 2 G so you just reconsider the
contribution for each rectangle and each
rectangle the contribution is a total
area of the rectangle or the part before
tau G so I - each time the total height
is 1 so we get a towel gia bound and the
second term we can also bound it by tau
G that's the total noise of idle time
before tau T of course he said most of G
so if you can see in the two pounds then
they expected CJ
under these conditions at most a to tau
D minus P IJ and expect the value of tau
J conditioned on Hg and the IJ is this
SJ plus P I deal with you so it's a
middle point so FG here s DF at spiaggia
here middle point so if you replace tau
e with this you will get 2 SJ + P IJ
which is what we needed
well what we need so finally we have the
answer ok to improve this boundness just
check what we can improve for the second
term so let's just assume this machine
is fully packed so at every time you
have exactly your total height one of
intervals otherwise you can just add
some dummy rectangles so maybe this
bound just by tau G is too pessimistic
that basically says that all the time
points before tau G are idle and you can
see suppose this is tau G here the
rectangles are something like this then
you hope to see many busy time snores
people Taji so if the rectangle
densities are very small with some
problems you are going to see next to
this rectangle and so tau G will be here
so you can see with reasonable
probability this we are you will have a
reasonable length of BD snorts before
tau G so that's ok and it's not hard to
see the only by the case is this so J is
here tau J is here but all the
rectangles
very known starting at time zero and in
time is very big compared to tell G them
with high probability
all those rectangles the Taliban will be
after two G so the total length will be
I don't ends will be tau G because the
tau J is here all those jobs are
scheduled after G so this is bad and so
that will give us the idea for
improvement so you can see this job she
must have smallness all those job G have
a big lens so what we are doing right
now is I'm trying to increase the
probability of J scheduled before those
jobs by shifting the mass of the
distribution from the left to the center
if you shift the semester on the left to
the center she will be more likely to be
scheduled before those jobs but on the
other hand I need to not increase so
expect the value of tau G conditioned on
IG and SJ remember original is SJ plus P
IJ / 2 as they are needed to make this
bound not increase so it's not harder to
prove that if I just have this
distribution so I cut the left side and
cut the right side I randomly choose tau
G between then it will improve this fact
of you but to do a better count what we
do is we parameterize this
biodistribution
so we choose a theta J from some
distribution and the net per gb SJ plus
theta J times P IJ then we express this
as the two terms here we bound the two
terms here by this form so the sum over
all rectangles are the contributing of r
then it suffices to do just a bound they
expected a contribution
of our to the integral solution divided
by the area of RP for tau G so the total
here overall our will be tau G as a
total here overall we are be the first
the two terms okay so this will depend
on theta and we discretize this
distribution theta and using LP to find
the best heceta but eventually we will
find a good fit for this distribution so
we will get a analytical proof for the
approximation ratio without using the
program so here is what the distribution
look like
so from zero to this point is an
increasing function so it's almost
Indian but it's a quadratic always very
small quadratic term and when theta is
after this is zero so right coincides
with our idea right we should shift mass
from the left to the center phone right
to the center to sum up we have a 1.8
786 approximation algorithm for
unrelated she's getting when job have
alright would hams so question for this
part in the grinded cap no we don't know
so you the property is a px heart and so
it should be at least to the hardness
but other than that I we did not try and
what kind of concerns come out of EDX
service what what apps
no I think it's very small when you say
a px hard you don't expect to be very
hard very nice
I'm just asking if there are no waves
but preemption and no wait release times
I think you think about its it may still
be hard
yeah that's for different a problem you
have weights but you don't have a rival
time we need states but none point or
non-preemptive
I don't think it's trivial I think it's
there and be hard about it I don't know
what's the best ratio
because this is just the first pie okay
what
1.05 yes another one do you mean if you
have a rival times two
okay I think I needed to be quick for
the second part - upon us to learn -
approximation for identical machine
scheduling but we have procedures
constraints so this is Jo are the
difference from the previous problem so
we have identical machines and we have
precedence constraints we may or may not
have arrival times for this it doesn't
matter but for simplicity we just assume
we don't have arrival times so since we
are in the identical machine model we
can just remove I the index I so we just
need X J's right now
so each xj t so if each xj is just a
rectangle from ace to a selfie idea with
height X J's and across each time point
we have a total height of M and for all
jobs for each job the total height of
rectangles is exactly one so this is the
picture you should have in mind and so
first we recover the four approximation
due to muna and then we try to see
what's not tight in the analysis and we
will improve it so we solve the LP and
then for every job chair in 90 creasing
order of this quantity so CJ - PG with
you so CJ is a fractional competition
time of J in the LP solution GJ is the
length of job J so we are we have
identical machines so there is only one
PJ and then we schedule this job J in a
greedy manner so with schedule J as
early as possible subject to constraints
firstly machine capacity constraint so
that means at any time the total in
number of intervals should not exceed m
and the second one is precedence
constraints you should a start you
should respect those constituents so for
example
these those jobs are scheduled and you
to schedule this ready job but I need to
schedule after this orange job so I
cannot i currently started here but i am
e equals 3 I should have found the first
times not where if I added this into
what the congestion remains 3 so this is
the time I scheduled this red job ok
this is the simple algorithm and you
people 0 for approximation so what's the
analysis so nights using here that CGA
to be the combination time of j in the
integral solution so we're then we break
here the CG into two parts so i is the
total length of idle times or not before
Teodor CG these are busy times or not so
when I say busy I mean all machines are
busy when i say i do' so that means at
least one machines either that's the
definition so i totem snorts I
compounded by 2 CJ so let's known so in
the busy I can also buy owned by 2 CJ so
that gives you a full approximation but
I am going to show this proof for busy
time some knots so it's actually very
straightforward you have this picture of
rectangles you mend so what's this with
CJ minus p GL with you is a horizontal a
coordinator of the math center of
rectangles for G so CJ's combination
time CJ minus P just starting time CJ
minus P G over 2 is center and consider
all jobs scheduled before J those jobs
should have send off mass before this CJ
minus P G over 2 so if we consider all
those rectangles to whole reason how my
center should it be before CG minus P G
over 2 but at each time point we have a
total height of M which is a m-- so you
can see the total area is that most two
times these times M
just the center of mass is here every
time point you have height M so you
cannot start before time zero so that's
the total area and by the definition
busy times laws so this divided by M is
the total length of B this not before
theodicy J which is at most the two CJ
okay so here comes our modification of
the algorithm so what we do is we will
choose a theta randomly between zero and
a half and I forget your jobs in this
order so CJ minus PJ plus theta P G so
that's sweet a fraction from the
beginning of the starting time for J so
again we will try to break into two
parts for idle times north we have a
show upper bound 1 over 1 minus theta
times CJ so this improves over 1 over 2
and but for busy time we have only get 1
over theta times CJ so if you want to
take the base that theta is 1/2 and you
will only get 4 so let's try to see why
we can only get 1 over theta times VG so
here is the simple example we think of
this job gia PJ is very small so CJ
minus 1 minus theta PJ's roughly CJ but
for all the other jobs and roughly theta
fraction of that job is before this CJ 1
minus V hides after peer after CJ so
this job will start at a time 0 and the
end here so you can see the total length
is 1 over 1 minus theta PG but you can
see the crucial observation is that this
cannot be bad for every theta so indeed
what we will show is that even if we
randomly choose theta between 0 and a
half P will be at most 2 CJ
instead of a integral of 1 over theta
which is the infinity so combining this
we get 2 for the busy time
but for idle time is the integral of 1
over 1 minus theta so it's 2 norm 2 so
that improves the for approximation so
to sum up we have a 2 plus 2 norm Q
approximation for scheduling on
identical machines with precedence
constraints so this is the algorithm
so there are few open problems so first
can we get a better approximation for
the two problems we studied so for the
related machine and related machine
scheduling we have a big X heart and for
this identical machine scheduling with
precedence constraints we have a UGC two
hardness and also can we improve the
related unrelated machine scheduling if
we don't have a robot hands right now we
have 1.5 minus C where C is very small
can you get an approximation with
reasonable see also can you improve the
reanimation scheduling when jobs have
procedures constraints currently needs
knock em over knock knock again okay
thank you no paper preemption actually
the ratio is even worse we get 1.999 one
so previous results to preemption with
its because I hope here we are using no
because of the help it is easy for our
solution but it's also easy for the
optimum so our LP only works for the non
pre-emptive reversion if you have a
preemption you don't have rectangles
other questions
yeah I think the completion is already
oh sorry yeah yeah but the value
equivalent up to a constant factor
yeah there's a recent hardness and
without assuming some hardness of some
cape part I'd graph problem you can get
a super constant but it's a very small
super constant
[Applause]